a sneak peek of the fourth installment
and the exhilarating john wick franchise
has finally arrived and even though it
isn't long a few small details that lie
within are worth diving into are you
ready
yeah keanu reeves has enjoyed a
remarkable run in hollywood one so
impressive that if he were to retire
tomorrow he'd have accomplished more
than most in the entertainment world
however his tenure isn't over yet as
evidenced by his work in the breakneck
high octane john wick franchise where he
plays the lead character
a retired assassin one of the best in
the game wick is brought back into the
criminal underworld following the death
of his dog which was the last gift his
late wife ever gave him suffice to say
it didn't welcome him back with open
arms following his blood-soaked quest
for revenge in 2014's john wick a
titular badass attempts to return to his
retirement
however he's once again pulled back into
the world of crime and corruption in
john wick chapter 2 where his situation
only goes from bad to worse upon
breaking one of the rules of the
continental its figurehead winston
excommunicates him from the organization
with a bounty placed on his head thus
throughout john wick's chapter 3
parabellum he's locked in a fight for
his life against the worst of the worst
who are hoping for a quick payday
despite the insurmountable odds against
him wig survives paving the way for john
wick chapter 4. in the midst of all the
action drama and questions john wick
chapter 4 teaser provides it also
reminds viewers that several key players
from the franchise's past will play a
part in the story one of the most
noteworthy is the bowery king that's
portrayed by keanu reeves former matrix
co-star lawrence fishburne he's seen a
handful of times throughout the trailer
urging wick to suit up likely for their
continued conflict with the mysterious
high table which once wicked dead and
dramatically blowing out a lit match
additionally the sneak preview gives us
a look at two other fan favorite series
staples who have become more important
to the john wick story as it has
unfolded winston makes a brief
appearance though he doesn't get
anything to do or say much like his
fellow continental hotel regular sharone
who locks eyes with clancy brown's
unnamed character at the hotel's front
desk time will tell how they'll factor
into wick's mission and where they stand
with the high table as it continues its
conflict with the baba yaga for a large
portion of the trailer john wick's
training in preparation for his attack
on the high table takes the spotlight he
repeatedly drives his bloodied fist into
markiwara post ignoring the pain and
pressing onward with the workout of
course he wouldn't dare go into battle
wearing a pair of baggy sweatpants and a
plain white t-shirt
well aware of this the bowery king
prepares a new yet familiar ensemble for
his unlikely ally
a black on black suit he presents it to
wick and asks him if he's ready to which
the legendary assassin simply replies
yeah
since the very first john wick film his
suits have become an integral part of
his persona no matter the opponent or
task at hand he always ensures he has a
tie around his neck his lapel's flat and
his dress shirt tucked in he's a
professional after all and it's vital to
keep up his image at all times at the
end of john wick chapter 3 parabellum he
was a broken crumbled mess of a man
whose suit was ragged and his body
destroyed his new john wick chapter 4
suit just lets us know that he's gotten
his mojo back and he's ready to get to
work
if hollywood has taught the world
anything it's that minor details can
mean far more than one might think in
the case of the john wick chapter 4
preview this concept may very well hold
water at the aforementioned moment when
wick confirms to the bowery king that
he's ready to go various drawings and
words scrawled on the wall behind him
occupy the screen around him
one such scribbling is the word past
right in front of his training area
which could point to a couple of things
for wick's future for one pass could
allude to his ongoing war with the high
table as he prepares to take it down he
may keep the word in front of him as a
reminder that he's finally putting his
past to rest once he succeeds then again
another reading of this is that he'll
have to use his past in order to be
successful during his years as an
assassin he didn't earn the nickname
barbara yaga for no reason rick has to
go back to the days when no one dared
cross him lest they wish to meet a swift
end if he wants to topple an entire
underground empire although this could
all just be tin foil hat speculation
we'll find out one way or the other when
john wick chapter 4 hits the big screen
on march 24 2023
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you